We know customers like low prices.
We know customers like big selection.
And we know that customers like fast delivery.
And those things are gonna be true ten years from now.
They're gonna be true 20 years from now,...
...so we can count on those things and we can put energy into them.
We know customers like their products fast.
And so we work on things that we know customers like.
What has worked at Amazon is focusing on the customer,...
...putting the customer first which is easy to say but difficult to do.
If you really are customer-centric, it's like being the host of a party.
You're holding the party for your guest.
Sometimes the host of the party is holding the party for the host of the party...
...and that leads to a different kind of party.